un autre jour sur le front un autre
message de celui qui prétend porter à
bout de bras la bataille la plus
déterminante pour la Russie en Ukraine
le grand patron du groupe paramilitaire
roi Agnar affirme aujourd'hui contrôler
toute la partie Est de Barma cette ville
martyre que les combats ont réduit en
poussière ce champ de bataille des plus
meurtriers nous Prigogine se plaint
constamment avec des photos troublantes
que ces hommes meurent comme de la chair
à canon faute de ressources du Kremlin
puis il y a des mises en scènes comme
celle-ci pour illustrer la frustration
de ces troupes qui plaide ouvertement
pour que Moscou leur envoie des
munitions
après vidéo le patron de Wagner accuse
le ministre de la défense de trahison ou
compétence
[Musique]
parle d'une jalousie flagrante qui s'est
installée entre deux grandes structures
militaires il dépeint prix gauche comme
un électron libre des plus efficaces
de la guerre
reste que ce bras de fer très public
entre deux armées fidèles à Poutine
soulève des questions sur ce qui donne
l'impression d'une ascension fulgurante
de Wagner et de son chef au sein de la
machine de guerre russe je pense que
c'est de la fumée ou de la poudre aux
yeux comme vous voulez Wagner est très
exposé médiatiquement mais en réalité ce
sont les armées russes qui organisent la
bataille de batmouth et Wagner travaille
en total coopération avec eux mais toute
l'attention qui est organisée entre prix
gaugine Wagner et le ministère de la
Défense pour l'essentiel et de la flûte
à mon sens il n'a aucun rôle réel
c'est-à-dire que si demain Poutine lui
retire son soutien il disparaît
exactement comme il est venu c'est à
dire des poubelles
car fut une époque ou pligogène agissait
presque dans l'ombre un petit criminel
devenu restaurateur il était surtout
connu comme étant le chef et le traiteur
du Kremlin en 2006 il recevait même
Vladimir Poutine et le président George
Bush dans son restaurant
Saint-Pétersbourg c'était bien avant
qu'il fonde son armée privée le groupe
Wagner dont les mercenaires ont mené
plusieurs opérations en catimini au fil
des ans pour mousser l'influence de la
Russie en Afrique en Syrie puis en
Ukraine dès 2014
aujourd'hui il se targue d'avoir une
armée forte de 50000 hommes pour la
plupart des criminels recrutés dans les
prisons de Russie
pigogne aura mis sur pied avec sa
brigade un régime des plus brutaux des
viols aux exécutions sommaires même
contre ses propres hommes qui refusent
de se battre de Solidar à barmouth et
malgré les apparences il est selon cette
analyse une simple marionnette un autre
outil de propagande du Kremlin la
bataille de bakkout est très importante
pour Vladimir Poutine et finalement
Prigogine sert de miroir aux alouettes
c'est à dire que c'est lui qui est
chargé d'énerver les ukrainiens et de
les convaincre qu'il devrait venir se
battre contre lui en fait les Ukrainiens
ont très bien compris sur les conseils
des pays alliés qui les soutiennent que
il fallait surtout garder leur force
huit mois de combat des milliers de
morts par mode quoi qu'il arrive est
devenu le symbole de tous les vices de
la guerre et de son horreur ici Tamara
Alteresco Radio-Canada Montréal